hallo deutsch schule punkt ch
hören und nachsprechen
[Musik]
lektion 49 hört zu und spricht nach
präpositionen mit dativ
lisa fährt mit dem bus
powell fällt mit dem tram
paul fährt mit dem tram alex fed nur mit
den öffentlichen verkehrsmitteln
alex fährt nur mit den öffentlichen
verkehrsmitteln
bist du schon mit der neuen u bahn
gefahren
bist du schon mit
u bahn gefahren
ich fahre
oft mit dem zug
ich fahre oft mit dem zug
ich muss zum arzt gehen
entschuldigung wie komme ich zum ida
platz
gehen sie geradeaus bis zur nächsten
kreuzung dann biegen sie links ab
manuela geht zu dominique manuela geht
zu dominique wir sind heute bei einem
guten freund zum abendessen eingeladen
wir sind
bei einem guten freund zum abendessen
eingeladen
meine frau
stunden beim friseur
unsere sitzung
beim anwalt hat drei stunden gedauert
unsere sitzung beim anbau
hat drei stunden gedauert
bei der nächsten kreuzung biegen sie
bitte links ab
bei der nähe
liegen sie bitte links ab
manu
ist bei dominik
manuell
da ist bei dominik
seit einem jahr wohne ich in zürich
ich bin seit zwei jahren
der schweiz
ich bin seit zwei jahren in der schweiz
er lernt seit drei monaten deutsch
[Musik]
nach der pause machen wir weiter
nach dem deutschkurs gehen wir in eine
bar
nach dem deutsch
das gehen wir in eine bar
ohne den schlüssel kann ich die tür
nicht öffnen
präpositionen mit akkusativ
ohne mein medikament geht es mir
schlecht
ohne
und geht es mir schlecht
wir gehen
ohne unsere männer aus
entschuldigung aber ohne einen gültigen
ausweis kommen sie hier nicht rein
das geschenk ist für meinen vater
das geschenk ist für meine mutter
das geschenk ist für mein kind
[Musik]
ich stimme gegen das neue gesetz
ich bin gegen
einen vorschlag ich bin gegen
ein vorschlag
nächste woche spielt meine
fußballmannschaft gegen den meister
ich baue einen zaun um einen garten
fahren sie um das haus hinter dem haus
gibt es noch parkplätze
fahren sie um das
aus hinter dem haus gibt es noch
parkplätze
mark
barandum seinen kopf er hatte einen
unfall
mag
trägt einen verband um seinen kopf er
hatte einen unfall
wir fahren
den gotthard tunnel
die fa
durch den gotthardtunnel
das flugzeug fliegt durch das gewitter